with presentation translator a Microsoft
Garage project you can display
translated subtitles in real time as you
speak the Adhan allows you to display
subtitles directly on your PowerPoint
presentation in any one of more than 60
supported text languages additionally up
to 100 audience members in the room can
follow along with the presentation in
their own language and on their own
phone tablet or computer let me show you
how
first off let's make sure you have a
working microphone connected to your PC
PowerPoint for Windows and of course an
internet connection you can find the
add-in on the Microsoft crash site at
WWE AMS forward slash presentation
translator make sure you do not have any
office apps open while it installs now
that we've installed the add-in open
your PowerPoint presentation go to the
slideshow ribbon and click on start
subtitles select the language you'll be
speaking the language you want to show
on-screen subtitles in and the
appropriate microphone source select
personalize speech recognition if you
want presentation translator to learn
from the content on your slides for
better subtitling this will help when
you're presenting specialized content
such as technical terms acronyms or
product and placement if you click on
additional settings you'll see the
default named presenter options for
where subtitles can be displayed and an
option to add instructional slide click
Next during this process presentation
translator will begin learning your
content and create custom speech models
for your presentation after this process
is complete click Save and start
subtitles to begin your presentation
the first slide on your PowerPoint will
contain a unique QR or conversation code
to share with audience members so they
can follow along in the language of
their choice on their phone tablet or PC
now you're ready to start presenting as
you can see as I talk the translator
add-in recognizes my voice and displays
this transcription in real time on the
screen this is powered by the Microsoft
translator live feature which allows me
to display subtitles in one of over 60
text languages now let's look at how to
join the conversation as someone in the
audience first download the Microsoft
translator app for iOS Android or
Windows launch the app click on the
multi person button to the right enter
the conversation code in this text box
enter your name and select a language
click enter
as you can see the
is speaking in English and the
transcription is showing up in Spanish
on this audience members phone so they
can follow along up to 500 users can
join from the audience each of them
choosing any of the more than 60 text
translation languages supported by
translator
while presenting you also have access to
additional settings such as the window
location font size and muting audience
questions until the end of your
presentation
if you can or don't want to install the
translator app you can also join this
conversation straight from your browser
by navigating to WWE translate IT
thanks for watching